how powerful is the president of the usa
Very powerful mediocre or impotent
that will be decided on tuesday
because there are midterm elections taking place in the usa
so that rule for joe biden
in the 2nd half of his term of office
does not become more difficult
he depends on it
that the parlament is behind him
in the usa,
the parliament has two chambers
the senate on the one hand and the house of representatives on the other
in the senate,
35 of the 100 members are newly elected
the House of Representatives is concerned with all 435 seats
in both chambers the democratic party has
of president biden so far the majority
but it is also thin
competition from the Republican Party
she really wants to take away from him
if she should make it
it will be quite difficult for both of them in the future
to implement its goals
because
the Republicans can have their political plans then
block in parliament
both then loses power clearly